crisis in Kenya the terror threat
crippling tourism in the interview
Kenyan opposition leader raila odinga
mr. Odinga you're the opposition leader
in Kenya right now you're on a political
trip for Germany to promote your country
to convince investors to come to Kenya
what are you telling German businessmen
why should they invest in Kenya well
investing in Kenya use one access to a
market of over 150 million people which
is good secondly as you know that Kenya
is liberalizing this is a process which
was started when I was the prime
minister that also offers a lot of other
opportunities like there's special
economic zones which are being
established right now we should offer
investors very good opportunities there
Kenya is trying to diversify the economy
through value addition to its material
materials which it is producing you
spend some 80 years in the German
Democratic Republican state that doesn't
exist anymore how do you see today's
unified Germany what is about Germany
now that most strikes you well under
aaron to your time before you know i'll
kill you when i lived here a safari 'no
i did not have any restrictions to a new
both sides of Germany I knew how painful
it was for the people to be separated
people having relatives on the other
side and they could never see I used to
be sent to go and rich relatives and
take letters and also come back with
presents the eastern side of Germany
when the wall eventually crumpled just
like a magic had actually taken place so
I am very
happy and grateful to the German people
that they've been able to unite and
become one again within my lifetime I
have read that when you were a
university student in East Germany you
were attracted to Maoist ideas later on
you named your firstborn son Fidel after
the Cuban President Fidel Castro how
would you describe your politics
nowadays well I was due to Maui as do i
you know in those young youthful days
you know there was a Vietnam War that
time we shall polarize the relationship
and the the world because some many
people were dying in Vietnam those are
days of student activism and these ideas
of international solidarity was very
appealing to the students at that time
the US imperialism she was seen as being
an aggressor that idea was very
appealing the students then Vietnam
became independent as you know and many
things change the Soviet Union became
then the the appearance in our view when
the US had knowledge transformed itself
and became more humane in dealing with
the the rest of the world and there's
also a lot of violation of human rights
within the Soviet empire itself so since
that time politics has changed let's
jump some 20 30 years ahead you tried
twice to become Kenyan president Kenyan
head of state do you still want to
become president will you be running for
office again yes see I got myself
involved
in a lot of struggle in Kenya my father
was himself involved in this political
struggle for democratization he had been
the vice president of the country but
disagreed with the President and formed
an opposition party which was banned by
the government and he was himself
arrested and put in political detention
so that is that the condition under
which I went back to Kenya ended up in
political detention I Institute the
camera for Parliament and then
eventually I became a candidate for the
presidency right now I'm leading the
major opposition movement in the country
and if my Patty and my collision
nominate me for the elections of course
of run but it's not my approach right
now my preoccupation is to organize my
party my collision to make it strong and
also to ensure that the lecturer
infrastructure is over hold so that they
can be a truly free and fair elections
without any kind of ringing the result
of the last presidential elections last
year was so close that you asked the
Kenyan court to order a recount
political crises like that usually mean
tourists are less keen to visit a
country how important in general is
tourism for the economy of your country
because of the dispute there's a lot of
violence and many people who died many
people lost their lives over 1300 people
were killed half a million people were
displaced and this is what you try to
avoid last time round that's why we
accepted a Supreme Court ruling tourism
because it's very critical very
put on to the key an economy recently
tourist bookings dropped sharply
following a string of a text by the
Islamist al-shabaab militia in June they
killed some 60 62 people in a text close
to tourist resorts what should Kenya do
to fight terrorism effectively well you
know that our situation is complicated
because we share a common border with
Somalia where we has not had a stable
regime since nineteen sixty there's
nearly 24 years so you had a population
of people who are now 20 / 20 years of
age we've never known peace in in in
Somalia it is of course a frightening
situation we when I was Prime Minister
we ordered our troops to move to the
border to secure our borders against
infiltration of the by the al-shabaab
right now there are some 4,000 Kenyan
soldiers which hold parts of Somalia
shall the government send more soldiers
more troops to to safeguard this buffer
zone against the influx of terrorists
now we have been actually talking
against this we have said that a
precious there should be limited and
that we should help this am I regime to
develop capacity to take over the
policing themselves we want some
analyzation of security with in Somali
and come up with a clear tempting of
exit from Somalia like the Americans did
in Iraq and also in Afghanistan so we
are not talking about withdrawal from
Somalia aside you talk about handing
over the security to the Somalis another
developing capacity of the Somali people
to be able to take responsibility for
their country if you sum it up how
dangerous is al-shabaab to your country
al-shabab recently has threatened to
come
for all of Kenya yeah shabab is a very
dangerous movement but as you know they
have already signed an agreement with
al-qaeda so the part of the
international terrorism organization and
that is how they get their their
supplies in terms of cash and also
reponds they have been carrying
retaliatory attacks because King and
troops actually inflicted very heavy
casualties on al-shabaab when we
attacked the Seaport of kismayo and
liberated it that was their main source
of supply now they are therefore
desperate and in that desperate
situation they have resorted to
desperate acts of targeting basically
civilian population but in our view is
that we should not surrender we must
basically be more vigilant in dealing
with these internal attacks on the other
hand we lack the international community
to play their part in containing this
spread of terrorism in that region when
you left Kenya to go to East Germany
your country was still a British colony
nowadays some 50 years after
independence does the colonial past
still play an important role in Kenya
after independence the relationship
between Kenya and Britain normalized so
the relationship between a must under
servants as the colonial the colonizer
and the colonized changed and became a
partnership so these days we enjoy a
very good relationship with with Britain
miss you is one of the development
partners and likewise also with the
unified Germany but de maniacally did
assist us even in this days of the
struggle the second liberation the
German diplomatic mission in Kenya was
very supportive of our efforts as the
progressive Kenyans who are fighting for
democratization of our country for a
repeal of section 2a our Constitution to
allow for formation of other political
parties so we have enjoyed some very
positive relationship with the Germany
faster West Germany at that time and now
United Federal Republic of Germany I la
Odinga former prime minister of Kenya
now the opposition leader I Nairobi
thank you very much for joining us on da
travail thank you thank you